[Musique]
le chanteur jean paul wolley avait
rejoint les services de la poste en
france en 1971
l'occasion rêvée pour lui de mettre la
réunion en l'air pendant longtemps il a
été le chanteur réunionnais le plus
connu de france est vraiment pas bon
même ah oui effectivement c'était lui
oui effectivement qui est bien adapté à
lille je dirait monsieur il fait beau
que vaut aujourd'hui ces réveils ou cinq
ans s'entraîne on se demandera lors des
réveillons jean-paul volet on a assuré
beaucoup avec son groupe les tropiques
il était omniprésent sur scène le
chanteur jean pierre boyer s'en souvient
très bien c'était surtout fantaisie
fantaisie il est mis à filmer ferrer les
gens et puis et jamais se mettait en
colère et puis il fait il fait une
chanson je veux rien il voit quelque
chose dessus de voyager dans le temps
il avait à l'époque on n'a pas de
portable et pourquoi la marche avec
magnéto les titres de jean-paul volnay
sont devenus des classiques de la
chanson locale
côté hôtels au centre le mot s'affirmer
et des as sera basée marie fatigué
l'attendiez
il a défait la chasse était le mot shit
et d'elle-même des changes de faire le
perthois
âgé de 68 ans jean paul wolley tire sa
révérence alors que la réunion s'apprête
à fêter
c'était un verbe qu'il chérissait
[Musique]